je suis très excité là
[Musique]
franchement ça va être une dinguerie
franchement regarde là regarde tout
autour
des gens qui s'installent très excité de
voir le premier tournoi et surtout la
phase finale ce soir à 20h ou à mon avis
ça va être fou avec avec le public et
tout il y a déjà un peu public quand
même un tout petit peu première fois que
je joue dans un tel cadre donc on va
voir comment comment ça va se passer
mais je sens bien
je crois que tout le monde est un peu en
freestyle ici donc on verra comment ça
se passe
à Paris en plein centre
[Musique]
à côté du Louvre avec la présence de
Baki qui est ouais qui a pris ses
bouteilles d'eau qui a pris c'est ouais
voilà il a son matos il est là mon
bacille en train de s'installer avec un
petit peu de retard mais mais mais mais
il est présent donc les quatre premiers
de cette poule se qualifieront pour la
phase finale il y aura après à 17h la
poule du capitaine qui m'a écrit ce
matin sur WhatsApp
il est costumé le capitaine
avec une position qui a plutôt bien pour
les plans
dans le micro là-bas ici le micro il va
le casser en fait tu lui tends il va
mettre des grands coups de micro non non
mais ouais non mais c'est une bonne
partie de Maxime et je me suis fait un
peu attraper dans l'ouverture et après
oui ça a l'air dur c'était dur ouais
c'était dur
et ça va c'est sympa pour jouer du coup
votre premier retour que vous êtes les
premiers à le faire à nous faire un
retour sur les sensations de jeu sympa
j'étais pas très bien quand je l'ai
retiré j'aurais pas dû le mettre en fait
c'est ça
trop tard
première partie contre le président
quand même bien fait peur mais il est
resté solide monsieur
de voir tout le monde en vrai à Kévin et
tout et non bah le format écoute ça
pouvoir jouer elle reste là jusqu'à ce
soir j'espère que ça va être le feu dans
l'arène mais en tout cas un vrai plaisir
c'est une première en vrai j'espère que
ce sera pas la dernière
pas mal quand même à ce jeu d'échec il
faut le dire j'ai réussi à perdre contre
le plus bas et l'eau c'est à dire qu'il
y a quelqu'un à 600 ah mais c'est toi
oui mais on va recommencer l'interview
non mais c'est donc j'ai perdu
parfait parfait par déco par déco une
déco ça marche parce que c'était moi la
déco que tout le monde se découvre c'est
un hommage avec qui mais c'est pas grave
je prends beaucoup de plaisir je suis
bien j'ai mon squelette de corbeau très
important contre les corbeaux dans ce
chat c'est vraiment c'est magnifique le
cas tout donc moi je viens de très loin
et je pense que il faut pas hésiter donc
la dernière fois j'avais pas pu venir
pour la somme battle donc j'ai failli me
faire pas trop naître d'une deuxième
fois j'ai réussi à venir il faut venir
c'est important on est bien
gagné par déco et après ça me participer
on est bien on est bien on est pas mal
[Musique]
on va essayer de gagner
il faut que tu leur fasses des signes
pour qu'il fasse plus de bruit là quand
il y a l'entrée des joueurs le deuxième
de la poule du capitaine ce n'est
personne d'autre que le capitaine
lui-même
[Applaudissements]
décollage imminent pour le capitaine
toujours pas
et donc celui qui a gagné la deuxième
poule il est venu et il fait partie
évidemment des favoris Christophe ton
chat qui la street c'est ma maison
il est à sa place donc on a on a tous
les joueurs qui sont là qui sont
normalement connectés c'est toujours
toujours le risque ben messieurs je vous
souhaite à tous bonne chance et puis moi
je vais rejoindre mon co commentateur de
choix puisque ce n'est personne d'autre
que le champion du monde Maxime Vacher
la grave
elle a travaillé un petit peu
l'endroit est cool l'ambiance est super
cool tu es super bien organisé en termes
de lumière tout ça donc franchement
c'est un super événement pour ça que je
suis content d'être là aussi et puis
maintenant il y a l'enjeu qui arrive il
y a tous les gros matchs donc c'est cool
je suis venu en mode repos parce que
j'avais pas spécialement envie de me
cramer mais c'est très possible que une
fois je me chauffe à jouer et un favori
pour cette phase finale le 13 évidemment
il fait un super tournoi le capitaine
mais bon il va être aussi hein c'est le
but souvent quel tournoi fantastique et
là très heureux de le retrouver à ce
niveau là et j'espère qu'il va jouer des
bons coups pour que ça soit aussi le
temps que les demi-finales en tout cas
aussi grand plaisir de voir des tels que
Arnaud mairesse stunt Magnus Marshall
qui est là racian c'est un plaisir ce
tournoi voilà et je pense que les gens
aiment bien aussi super bien ici merci
de suivre Kevin de nous suivre pour les
échecs c'est top bah qui en fait le
problème c'est que c'est mon anti moi
quoi ça c'est moi en plus fort donc gros
problème je sais pas ce que je vais
faire
bah qui c'est la classe mondiale c'est
top 5 mondial c'est le monstre je sais
que j'ai mes chances que c'est du Blitz
et du coup voilà en tout cas très
heureux d'être là pour célébrer les
échecs et cet événement énorme quoi
[Musique]
le capitaine
et il est de retour
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que tu veux nous dire un petit
mot avant cette finale
[Musique]
je joue contre le pire adversaire
possible Etienne c'est moi en meilleure
tonnerre d'applaudissement pour les deux
armes avant
et on va espérer qui nous offre une
magnifique finale et allez c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention dame C3 et ça va gagner bon le
13 ça y est les amis et c'est terminé
victoire de Baki dans cette compétition
qui remporte la première édition bah ça
Sébastien Mazet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]